Seção 1 de Dom Casmurro.
Esta é uma gravação LibriVox. Todas as gravações LibriVox estão em domínio público. Para mais informações, ou para ser um voluntário, por favor visite librivox.org.
Dom Casmurro, de Machado de Assis.
Capítulo 1. Do título.
Uma noite destas, vindo da cidade para o Engenho Novo, encontrei no trem da Central um rapaz aqui do bairro, que eu conheço de vista e de chapéu. Cumprimentou-me, sentou-se ao pé de mim, falou da lua e dos ministros, e acabou recitando-me versos. A viagem era curta, e os versos pode ser que não fossem inteiramente maus. Sucedeu, porém, que, como eu estava cansado, fechei os olhos três ou quatro vezes; tanto bastou para que ele interrompesse a leitura e metesse os versos no bolso.
— Continue, disse eu acordando. — Já acabei, murmurou ele. — São muito bonitos.
Vi-lhe fazer um gesto para tirá-los outra vez do bolso, mas não passou do gesto; estava amuado. No dia seguinte entrou a dizer de mim nomes feios, e acabou alcunhando-me Dom Casmurro. Os vizinhos, que não gostam dos meus hábitos reclusos e calados, deram curso à alcunha, que afinal pegou. Nem por isso me zanguei. Contei a anedota aos amigos da cidade, e eles, por graça, chamam-me assim, alguns em bilhetes: "Dom Casmurro, domingo vou jantar com você."—"Vou para Petrópolis, Dom Casmurro; a casa é a mesma da Renânia; vê se deixas essa caverna do Engenho Novo, e vai lá passar uns quinze dias comigo."—"Meu caro Dom Casmurro, não cuide que o dispenso do teatro amanhã; venha e dormirá aqui na cidade; dou-lhe camarote, dou-lhe chá, dou-lhe cama; só não lhe dou moça."
Não consultes dicionários. Casmurro não está aqui no sentido que eles lhe dão, mas no que lhe pôs o vulgo de homem calado e metido consigo. Dom veio por ironia, para atribuir-me fumos de fidalgo. Tudo por estar cochilando! Também não achei melhor título para a minha narração; se não tiver outro daqui até ao fim do livro, vai este mesmo. O meu poeta do trem ficará sabendo que não lhe guardo rancor. E com pequeno esforço, sendo o título seu, poderá cuidar que a obra é sua. Há livros que apenas terão isso dos seus autores; alguns nem tanto.
Capítulo 2. Do livro.
Agora que expliquei o título, passo a escrever o livro. Antes disso, porém, digamos os motivos que me põem a pena na mão.
Vivo só, com um criado. A casa em que moro é própria; fi-la construir de propósito, levado de um desejo tão particular que me vexa imprimi-lo, mas vá lá. Um dia, há bastantes anos, lembrou-me reproduzir no Engenho Novo a casa em que me criei na antiga Rua de Matacavalos, dando-lhe o mesmo aspecto e economia daquela outra, que desapareceu. Construtor e pintor entenderam bem as indicações que lhes fiz: é o mesmo prédio assobradado, três janelas de frente, varanda ao fundo, as mesmas alcovas e salas. Na principal destas, a pintura do teto e das paredes é mais ou menos igual, umas grinaldas de flores miúdas e grandes pássaros que as tomam nos bicos, de espaço a espaço. Nos quatro cantos do teto as figuras das estações, e ao centro das paredes os medalhões de César, Augusto, Nero e Massinissa, com os nomes por baixo. Não alcanço a razão de tais personagens. Quando fomos para a casa de Matacavalos, já ela estava assim decorada; vinha do decênio anterior. Naturalmente era gosto do tempo meter sabor clássico e figuras antigas em pinturas americanas. O mais é também análogo e parecido. Tenho chácara, flores, legume, uma casuarina, um poço e lavadouro. Uso louça velha e mobília velha. Enfim, agora, como outrora, há aqui o mesmo contraste da vida interior, que é pacata, com a exterior, que é ruidosa.
O meu fim evidente era atar as duas pontas da vida, e restaurar na velhice a adolescência. Pois, senhor, não consegui recompor o que foi nem o que fui. Em tudo, se o rosto é igual, a fisionomia é diferente. Se só me faltassem os outros, vá; um homem consola-se mais ou menos das pessoas que perde; mas falto eu mesmo, e esta lacuna é tudo. O que aqui está é, mal comparando, semelhante à pintura que se põe na barba e nos cabelos, e que apenas conserva o hábito externo, como se diz nas autópsias; o interno não aguenta tinta. Uma certidão que me desse vinte anos de idade poderia enganar os estranhos, como todos os documentos falsos, mas não a mim. Os amigos que me restam são de data recente; todos os antigos foram estudar a geologia dos campos santos. Quanto às amigas, algumas datam de quinze anos, outras de menos, e quase todas creem na mocidade. Duas ou três fariam crer nela aos outros, mas a língua que falam obriga muita vez a consultar os dicionários, e tal frequência é cansativa. Entretanto, vida diferente não quer dizer vida pior; é outra coisa. A certos respeitos, aquela vida antiga aparece-me despida de muitos encantos que lhe achei; mas é também exato que perdeu muito espinho que a fez molesta, e, de memória, conservo alguma recordação doce e feiticeira. Em verdade, pouco apareço e menos falo. Distrações raras. O mais do tempo é gasto em hortar, jardinar e ler; como bem, e não durmo mal.
Ora, como tudo cansa, esta monotonia acabou por exaurir-me também. Quis variar, e lembrou-me escrever um livro. Jurisprudência, filosofia e política acudiram-me, mas não me acudiram as forças necessárias. Depois, pensei em fazer uma História dos Subúrbios, menos seca que as memórias do Padre Luís Gonçalves dos Santos, relativas à cidade; era obra modesta, mas exigia documentos e datas, como preliminares, tudo árido e longo. Foi então que os bustos pintados nas paredes entraram a falar-me e a dizer-me que, uma vez que eles não alcançavam reconstituir-me os tempos idos, pegasse da pena e contasse alguns. Talvez a narração me desse a ilusão, e as sombras viessem perpassar ligeiras, como ao poeta, não o do trem, mas o do Fausto: Aí vindes outra vez, inquietas sombras...
Fiquei tão alegre com esta ideia, que ainda agora me treme a pena na mão. Sim, Nero, Augusto, Massinissa, e tu, grande César, que me incitas a fazer os meus comentários, agradeço-vos o conselho, e vou deitar ao papel as reminiscências que me vierem vindo. Deste modo, viverei o que vivi, e assentarei a mão para alguma obra de maior tomo. Eia, comecemos a evocação por uma célebre tarde de novembro, que nunca me esqueceu. Tive outras muitas, melhores, e piores, mas aquela nunca se apagou do espírito. É o que vais entender, lendo.
Capítulo 3. A denúncia.
Ia a entrar na sala de visitas, quando ouvi proferir o meu nome e escondi-me atrás da porta. A casa era a da Rua de Matacavalos, o mês novembro, o ano é que é um tanto remoto, mas eu não hei de trocar as datas à minha vida só para agradar às pessoas que não amam histórias velhas; o ano era de 1857.
— D. Glória, a senhora persiste na ideia de meter o nosso Bentinho no seminário? É mais que tempo, e já agora pode haver uma dificuldade. — Que dificuldade?
Minha mãe quis saber o que era. José Dias, depois de alguns instantes de concentração, veio ver se havia alguém no corredor; não deu por mim, voltou e, abafando a voz, disse que a dificuldade estava na casa ao pé, a gente do Pádua.
— A gente do Pádua? — Há algum tempo estou para lhe dizer isto, mas não me atrevia. Não me parece bonito que o nosso Bentinho ande metido nos cantos com a filha do Tartaruga, e esta é a dificuldade, porque se eles pegam de namoro, a senhora terá muito que lutar para separá-los.
— Não acho. Metidos nos cantos? É um modo de falar. Em segredinhos, sempre juntos. Bentinho quase que não sai de lá. A pequena é uma desmiolada; o pai faz que não vê; tomara ele que as coisas corressem de maneira que... Compreendo o seu gesto; a senhora não crê em tais cálculos, parece-lhe que todos têm a alma cândida... — Mas, Sr. José Dias, tenho visto os pequenos brincando, e nunca vi nada que faça desconfiar. Basta a idade; Bentinho mal tem quinze anos. Capitú fez catorze à semana passada; são dois criançolas. Não se esqueça que foram criados juntos, desde aquela grande enchente, há dez anos, em que a família Pádua perdeu tanta coisa; daí vieram as nossas relações. Pois eu hei de crer?... Mano Cosme, você que acha?
O Tio Cosme respondeu com um ora! que, traduzido em vulgar, queria dizer: "São imaginações do José Dias; os pequenos divertem-se, e eu divirto-me; onde está o gamão?"
— Sim, creio que o senhor está enganado. — Pode ser, minha senhora. Oxalá tenham razão; mas creia que não falei senão depois de muito examinar. Em todo caso, vai sendo tempo.
Minha mãe interrompeu-o.
— Bem, uma vez que não perdeu a ideia de o fazer padre, tem-se ganho o principal. Bentinho há de satisfazer os desejos de sua mãe. E depois, a igreja brasileira tem altos destinos. Não esqueçamos que um bispo presidiu a Constituinte, e que o Padre Feijó governou o império. Governou como a cara dele, atalhou o Tio Cosme, cedendo a antigos rancores políticos. — Perdão, doutor, não estou defendendo ninguém, estou citando. O que eu quero dizer é que o clero ainda tem grande papel no Brasil.
— Você o que quer é um capote; ande, vá buscar o gamão. Quanto ao pequeno, se tem de ser padre, realmente é melhor que não comece a dizer missa atrás das portas. Mas olhe cá, mana Glória, há mesmo necessidade de o fazer padre? — É promessa, há de cumprir-se. — Sei que fez promessa... mas, uma promessa assim... não sei... Creio que, bem pensado... Você que acha, prima Justina? — Eu?
Verdade é que cada um sabe melhor de si, continuou o Tio Cosme. Deus é que sabe de todos. Contudo, uma promessa de tantos anos... Mas que é isso, mana Glória? Está chorando? Ora esta! Pois isto é coisa de lágrimas? Minha mãe assoou-se sem responder. Prima Justina creio que se levantou e foi ter com ela. Seguiu-se um alto silêncio, durante o qual estive a pique de entrar na sala, mas outra força maior, outra emoção, não pude ouvir as palavras que o Tio Cosme entrou a dizer. Prima Justina exortava: "Prima Glória! Prima Glória!" José Dias desculpava-se: "Se soubesse, não teria falado, mas falei pela veneração, pela estima, pelo afeto, para cumprir um dever amargo, um dever amaríssimo..."
Capítulo 4. Um dever amaríssimo.
José Dias amava os superlativos. Era um modo de dar feição monumental às ideias; não as havendo, servia a prolongar as frases. Levantou-se para ir buscar o gamão, que estava no interior da casa. Cosi-me muito à parede, e vi-o passar com as suas calças brancas engomadas, presilhas, rodaque e gravata de mola. Foi dos últimos que usaram presilhas no Rio de Janeiro, e talvez neste mundo. Trazia as calças curtas para que lhe ficassem bem esticadas. A gravata de cetim preto, com um aro de aço por dentro, imobilizava-lhe o pescoço; era então moda. O rodaque de chita, veste caseira e leve, parecia nele uma casaca de cerimônia. Era magro, chupado, com um princípio de calva; teria os seus cinquenta e cinco anos. Levantou-se com o passo vagaroso do costume, não aquele vagar arrastado dos preguiçosos, mas um vagar calculado e deduzido, um silogismo completo, a premissa antes da consequência, a consequência antes da conclusão. Um dever amaríssimo!
Capítulo 5. O agregado.
Nem sempre ia naquele passo vagaroso e rígido. Também se decompunha em acionados, era muita vez rápido e lépido nos movimentos, tão natural nesta como naquela maneira. Outrossim, ria largo, se era preciso, de um grande riso sem vontade, mas comunicativo, a tal ponto as bochechas, os dentes, os olhos, toda a cara, toda a pessoa, todo o mundo pareciam rir nele. Nos lances graves, gravíssimo.
Era nosso agregado desde muitos anos; meu pai ainda estava na antiga fazenda de Itaguaí, e eu acabava de nascer. Um dia, apareceu ali, vendendo-se por médico homeopata; levava um Manual e uma botica. Havia então um andanço de febres; José Dias curou o feitor e uma escrava, e não quis receber nenhuma remuneração. Então meu pai propôs-lhe ficar ali vivendo, com pequeno ordenado. José Dias recusou, dizendo que era justo levar a saúde à casa de sapé do pobre.
— Quem lhe impede que vá a outras partes? Vá onde quiser, mas fique morando conosco. Voltarei daqui a três meses. Voltou dali a duas semanas, aceitou casa e comida, sem outro estipêndio, salvo o que quisessem dar por festas. Quando meu pai foi eleito deputado e veio para o Rio de Janeiro com a família, ele veio também, e teve o seu quarto ao fundo da chácara. Um dia, reinando outra vez febres em Itaguaí, disse-lhe meu pai que fosse ver a nossa escravatura. José Dias deixou-se estar calado, suspirou e acabou confessando que não era médico. Tomara este título para ajudar a propaganda da nova escola, e não o fez sem estudar muito e muito; mas a consciência não lhe permitia aceitar mais doentes.
— Mas você curou das outras vezes. — Creio que sim; o mais acertado, porém, é dizer que foram os remédios indicados nos livros. Eles, sim, eles, abaixo de Deus. Eu era um charlatão, não negue; os motivos do meu procedimento podiam ser e eram dignos: a homeopatia é a verdade, e, para servir à verdade, menti; mas é tempo de restabelecer tudo. Não foi despedido, como pedia então. Meu pai já não podia dispensá-lo. Tinha o dom de se fazer aceito e necessário; dava-se por falta dele, como de pessoa da família. Quando meu pai morreu, a dor que o pungiu foi enorme, disseram-me, não me lembra. Minha mãe ficou-lhe muito grata, e não consentiu que ele deixasse o quarto da chácara. Ao sétimo dia, depois da missa, ele foi despedir-se dela.
— Fique, José Dias. — Obedeço, minha senhora.
Teve um pequeno legado no testamento, uma apólice e quatro palavras de louvor. Copiou as palavras, encaixilhou-as e pendurou-as no quarto, por cima da cama. "Esta é a melhor apólice," dizia ele muita vez. Com o tempo, adquiriu certa autoridade na família, certa audiência ao menos; não abusava, e sabia opinar obedecendo. Ao cabo, era amigo, não direi ótimo, mas nem tudo é ótimo neste mundo. E não lhe suponhas alma subalterna; as cortesias que fizesse vinham antes do cálculo que da índole. A roupa durava-lhe muito; ao contrário das pessoas que enxovalham depressa o vestido novo, ele trazia o velho escovado e liso, cerzido, abotoado, de uma elegância pobre e modesta. Era lido, posto que de atropelo, o bastante para divertir ao serão e à sobremesa, ou explicar algum fenômeno, falar dos efeitos do calor e do frio, dos polos e de Robespierre. Contava muita vez uma viagem que fizera à Europa, e confessava que a não sermos nós, já teria voltado para lá; tinha amigos em Lisboa, mas a nossa família, dizia ele, abaixo de Deus, era tudo.
"Abaixo ou acima?" perguntou-lhe o Tio Cosme um dia. "Abaixo," repetiu José Dias, cheio de veneração. E minha mãe, que era religiosa, gostou de ver que ele punha Deus no devido lugar, e sorriu aprovando. José Dias agradeceu de cabeça. Minha mãe dava-lhe de quando em quando alguns cobres; Tio Cosme, que era advogado, confiava-lhe a cópia de papéis de autos.
Fim da seção 1.